so I want to manage expectations with
you on the future value tame impd
podcast so we have a very mutual
understanding of what's going to happen
here and you can't say you never told me
okay so I want to manage expectation
with our relationship moving forward and
I'm talking you and I me being the
content creator you know valuetainment
PVD podcast whatever we're doing here
and you being a fan of it or you being a
follower of it or somebody that consumes
some of the content maybe you like some
maybe you don't like some here's what I
want to manage with you moving forward
I'll get messages where people will say
I miss your old content from seven years
ago where was only business I miss the
fact that I used to say this and some
people will say I like the way you
interviewed him but not her I like the
fact that you bring these guests not
those guests look for those of you that
love my content and fully agree with me
be patient I'm going to interview
somebody you're not going to like and
I'm gonna say some stuff that you're not
going to agree with and I'm fully okay
with that for those of you who watch
this who can't stand in my content and
can't stand what I stand for be patient
I'm going to interview somebody you're
going to like and I want to say
something you're going to agree and you
as much as you don't want it you're
going to like me and you can say I kind
of like this guy it's gonna happen you
just have to be patient my goal and
outcome of what I do with this content
and I hope it inspires you to be
thinking about this as well my goal and
outcome isn't for you to like me a long
time ago and I created my own definition
of leadership and I created a score
where in life we all want to please
everybody in our life I had a meeting
yesterday with our executive team and I
explained three different points to them
for some people and I said you know in
life we want to please the people in our
lives you want to please your wife your
wife wants to please you or you want to
please your mom and dad your parents
want to please you or your kids etc etc
I said we all have a score I said if
your score is a hundred and you want to
please everybody
you're not a leader if your score is a
zero and you could care less about
pleasing anybody you're an okay
my goal isn't to be a hundred nor is my
goal to be zero my goal is to be around
50 to understand what core convictions I
have feel comfortable to share it
knowing you may or may not agree with it
but I don't go to sleep worrying about
oh my gosh I got 93 people that didn't
like what I had to say today I don't
want to sleep over that I chose to be a
leader in life and my definition of
leadership isn't to please everyone in
my life makes sense and you're a part of
it just the other day I'll give you an
example I was reading an article I wrote
six years ago seven years ago when I
left California says Dear California
this is why I'm leaving you and I wrote
10 things I'm going to miss about
California 10 reasons why I'm leaving
California and if I was the governor of
California these are the four things I
would do and I read them like what an
innocent mindset seven years ago today
it would be a lot deeper and at that
point the level of depth was maybe two
three layers today would be seven eight
nine layers all right I'm gonna go out
that guy's grown it's pretty cool you
were 37 then thinking like that you're
44 now I'm sure at 50 years old I'm
going to watch some of my content today
I'm going to say I like what you said
but I'm telling you Pat you were missing
this this this and I know I'm going to
go through that and I'm so looking
forward to it but I'm okay with that
here's what direction we're going to
next some people say man why do you talk
about Iran or politics or Trump or
DeSantis or Biden or taxes or minimum
wage you know stay away from politics I
can't help myself these things matter to
me because as I become a parent and as I
age and I see different issues in my
life and I pay tens of millions out in
dollars in taxes I look at policies in a
different when I say so if I am
investing into this company called
United States of America and I'm putting
all this money into it I want to see
some results I want to see some I want
to see some accountability you think
about it in a different way if I have
kids four of them and I'm contributing
to society I want to make so I'm seeing
what's happening how they're being
treated and what values principles
movies shows what are you trying to
inject into my kids what do you want
them to think about is it to think big
or is it to dream bigger or is it to
make them feel guilty I care about those
things that I'm going through that and
some of you guys may be aging with me
and you may be my age you're saying I
like this content some of you guys may
be in your 20s some of them may be 14
say man kind of look at Pat as a father
figure or uncle or Mentor I someone
maybe my agent you're completely
disagree but it's totally fine my idea
on how I learn is through debates so I'm
gonna bring people from both sides and
one minute the capitalist conservatives
will say I can't believe you brought
David Pacman or Kyle kulinski or Roland
Martin or Jank from Young Turks how
could you do that do you understand what
these people stand for I enjoy the
conversation so how could you bring that
communist or slavo Zizek or Richard wall
for you I enjoyed this conversation but
you realize what one this guy said do
you know one guy on your show it said
the two most influential powerful men
greatest men of all time is Mao are you
like serious you think that's good yes I
want to have the conversation to see how
a communist Professor from Riverside can
say things like this I enjoyed that next
minute how can you bring a person like
Roger Stone and this person and they're
talking this about politics and that guy
in this yeah exactly I'm trying to learn
okay I'm trying to exactly what the
other guys are not doing the other guys
just want to talk to people that fully
agree with them I don't want to just do
that I want to talk to people that I
agree with to disagree and I want to
talk to people that I disagree with to
see if we have an area of agreement and
then I try to bring those two together
and we're going to continue doing this
so if this upsets you already I want to
manage expectations you're going to be
upset a lot go watch other content not
ours but if you like to see these types
of things and you get to make the
decision and say today I don't like what
Pat said I think his agreement was wrong
but I'm curious to know what angle he's
going to take next I agree with what he
had to say today this was kind of cool
let's go on this journey together okay
and FYI you only know this much of what
we're working on with valuetainment less
than one percent people have no clue
behind closed doors what we're building
right now without attainment we're
talking to many different talents that
we'll be bringing here many different
Technologies we're talking to right now
tens of millions of dollars that we're
planning on making Investments we are
having major
I don't want to give it away companies
that have access to billions of dollars
that I've done business within the past
and we've made money together who are
waiting to give 100 200 300 million
dollars to grow with us because they
want to own a piece of this thing
division is Big the vision is something
that's a 40-year vision on what we want
to do gradually you'll learn more and
more about what we're doing but I just
want to kind of set the tone here where
you know what we're going to next if you
like it great if you don't create and if
you support it fantastic stay tuned
there's going to be many different
opportunities in areas to support us and
we have not yet asked for you know money
and things like that but if we launch
some of the next products we are going
to be having subscriptions and monthly
memberships and all that stuff of course
we have our sales courses and some of
the other things that we have but I'm
talking Next Level media products that
we'll be developing so stay tuned for
that but just so you know you hear it
from me I am so
confident and comfortable with the
approach we're taking and I get people
that I pull me aside at events on this
ah you know I agree I just I can't
believe this I'm cool with that we're
gonna get better we have a very big
Vision we think we're super necessary
today we think the Market's filled with
a lot of other people that are necessary
but we think we're going to do our part
the next 5 10 15 20 years I wish you can
come here just kind of see some of the
movies because I see the movie in my
every time I go to sleep at night I
think about the movie and what things
we're going to be doing with God's help
and hopefully you will join us on this
crazy wild journey and you'll support us
along the way we are going to make some
mistakes telling you right now and we're
going to do some major major things but
you don't do one without the other we're
not perfect we don't solve for
Perfection we solve for Progress we
solve for growth we saw for the vision
that we have in place and uh God willing
collectively together because we need
the Right audience that likes our
philosophy together we can make a Major
Impact in the world so we can look back
and say hey this was kind of exciting on
what we did together you supported us we
supported you together we want to have
these bigger conversations and we were
able to bully the bullies that are out
there because to face those bullies is
going to take a lot of courage and
collectively we cannot alone we
definitely need your support and help to
do that the right ones that are
comfortable with our philosophy
collectively I think we can win this War
battle whatever you want to call it the
next 5 10 15 20 years I will be facing
so that's the vision of what's going to
be happening with value team in the next
five 10 20 years and I thought it was
very important for you to hear it from
me
foreign
[Music]